what do you want to see happen I want to
see well in general I want to see people
coming together and raising their voices
and being inspired to take action so
what do we do we understand that
corporations have have to be reined in
held on a leash to stop them from doing
anything they want to the next insane
idea Lucian is standing up fighting back
right now bringing millions of people
into resistance but building a movement
for a natural revolution and a new
society what do you want to happen a
whole new side but do you want to frack
do you want win do you want solar maybe
we need green energy we need to bring
forward green energy but that can only
happen really under a new socialist
society I wouldn't want to turbine in my
yard either okay and I looked at a solar
but I wouldn't want to be so effective
MIT in my yard community so what do you
want to do exactly I don't have the
answer okay I think the kids do and
they're being stifled if you've a new is
a new idea you're wrong they forget rid
one would you like to see civil
penalties or I mean criminal penalties
against corporate directors and and
various other anybody involved in
fracking Jamboree and Danlos climate
change denying
how can you ignore those droughts and
fires but someday they may become one
okay so what sort of changes do you want
to see happen I think that we need more
renewable energy we need to be putting
money into alternatives to oil and
burning coal the principle issue seems
to be that a lot of the new energy is
really really expensive and that's the
reason people are using that's the point
I'm looking to leave oh it's not true
it's not true you own everything they
own our governments they own they own
all the industry they've run this
country they run this world but they run
this country I think your question
what's the question in the right place
which is it can't be about poor people
having to pay more we live in a
grotesque era of where we have
everything we want all the time right
now I think having less is actually very
freeing I think we just have way too
much stuff and and we use energy like
it's never going to run out and it will
run out eventually turn or turn
everything off everyone turn everything
off we try with you off I really need my
cell phone I don't
ah climate justice now